[Captioned via Y Translator]
Slime is some cool stuff
with a weird texture,
and today, we're going
to see what happens
if we try and take all
of the water out of it,
and then we'll see
what happens if we try
and put the water back in.
[Music]
Slime has been entertaining
children for years and years
under several different names,
and it's a really cool weird substance.
And it's something that
you can also make at home,
which is pretty fun.
But we're curious
what would happen
if you took all of the liquid
out of this slime.
What would be left?
What would the texture
be like then?
Here's the basic idea.
We've got some
store-bought slime, and
we'll make some homemade slime.
We're going to try
and dehydrate both,
and then see if they
can be turned into a powder.
and rehydrate it.
[Music]
One cup of water,
1/2 teaspoon of borax...
[Music]
Half a cup of water,
and 5 ounces of clear glue.
Add a few drops of color.
[Music]
Now, I am going to mix
everything inside our pitcher
'cause it's gonna hold
everything really nicely.
[Music]
That's a great color of slime.
So now, we have
these two metal trays,
and this is where we're going
to have our slime sit in
as it dehydrates.
So, try and get
the purple one out.
Slime!
That's truly delightful.
Look at that.
I wonder if it's going
to stick a lot to the tray.
It is largely made
of glue after all.
It's kind of cool.
This stuff like
seems really thick
and gelatinous and all that.
But if you leave slime out,
if you make homemade slime,
and then you just leave it
for like two days,
all of those bubbles
will actually just
rise right up out of it.
It takes a long time,
but you end up with just
like perfectly clear slime,
until you play with it again,
then you get a lot more bubbles
in it all of a sudden.
Now, the green.
Splat.
We certainly have
different textures
in our two slimes here.
This green stuff really likes
to gather up a lot more.
The purple did an okay job
of spreading out.
I don't necessarily need
it to be all stretched out,
but I suspect it
will dehydrate better
if it is.
More surface area, more liquid
can escape more easily.
Those are fantastic colors.
Now, these are going
to take a while.
I'm probably going to end up
dehydrating them for several days,
and during that time,
I'll probably also
take them out.
Maybe flip them over
if one side seems
to be completely dry,
and the other one doesn't.
I'll probably switch them back
and forth a little bit,
but I'll just try
and do whatever it takes
to make sure they get a lot
of even heat and air to really
dry out completely.
[Music]
It's been a few days,
and both of our types
of slime have completely
dehydrated inside our dehydrator.
They took rather
different amounts of time.
Our Green store-bought slime
completely dried out
till it was just plasticky
and brittle in--
I think it was
less than 24 hours.
Our homemade slime,
our purple stuff,
this took about twice as long,
and I had to flip it over.
This piece actually just kind
of came unstuck from the metal,
but it was still softer
on one side.
So I'd like flip it over
and let it dry out more.
But at this point,
I think both
of them are completely dry.
You can see that's very brittle.
Over here, we've just
got flakes of it,
and now, we're going to see
if we can turn these
into a powder,
and if we can turn them
into powder,
can we add water back
into them and turn them
back into liquid slime?
So let's take
our two different
dried out slimes,
which have remarkably
different textures,
and see what we can do
to powderize them.
I have a couple
of different blenders here.
I've got like a little
Magic Bullet, and then
I've got a big old Blendtec
because this stuff is
really tough.
But the green stuff is
very thin and brittle,
and so I'm pretty sure I
can just crush this down,
and put it in our little
Magic Bullet size blender,
and that'll just
turn it into dust.
So let's start off
with that one.
Let's see how well it works.
Let's see if I'm right about how
easily it comes apart,
and hopefully,
it comes off of the metal nice
and easily as well.
[Music]
Definitely does stick
to our foil tray a fair amount,
some places.
It's kind of hard to get
off of the metal.
[Music]
So if I were to try this again,
I'd probably try
and find like a Teflon
coated pan or something.
See if it slides off of that more easily.
[Music]
All right, we've still got
a little bit stuck to our tray,
but I think we've done
a fairly good job
of getting most of it off.
I'd say we've got at least 75%.
[Music]
All right. Our blender,
I think has done a pretty
good job of chopping that up,
but I want to go even finer
if I can.
I'm gonna throw this
in our mortar and pestle.
Neon green powder, in
ground up old-fashioned style.
[Music]
It's a pretty
good powder right there.
Alright.
Got our green ground up.
Let's move on to our purple.
[Music]
I think our blender could probably
handle these at full-size,
but...
Just going to start
by chopping it all down
a little bit smaller.
[Music]
It doesn't even land.
Just like hovering above it.
[Music]
Probably fine.
The lid has some vent holes,
and it definitely had some powder
escaping through that.
Okay, that definitely
took it down quite a bit
but there's still some fairly
large chunks in there.
This is like the consistency
of about maybe not flour,
but close.
This is like the consistency
of raw sugar.
So I'm going to clean this out,
and try blending it even finer
in this blender.
See if this is tough enough
to break that up anymore.
Might've done a little.
Definitely don't think
it's as fine of a powder.
We'll try putting in
the mortar and pestle,
and seeing if that makes
it any smaller.
I think this mixture is
just sort of like
a flexible enough compound that
it doesn't crush very well.
Whereas the other stuff dried
into such a rigid plastic.
It is able to turn into dust.
This is more like sand.
Alright.
Let's start out
with our purple stuff.
We're going to try
just taking a spoonful
of our purple sand here,
and we're going to add
little bits of water
and stir it,
and see if it
sort of dissolves back in.
It also may take a little while
for these larger pieces
to really absorb all
the water they've lost,
or maybe it'll never work.
I haven't tried this before,
but let's find out.
[Music]
We're definitely making a pulp.
Certainly wouldn't
call it slime.
I also don't think
this is enough water.
I'm not sure what
it's going to do,
but given the ratio
of what this was
before it started,
and what it is now,
I think this is going
to be too little water
for it to properly
absorb everything.
[Music]
This is forming into sort of like
a gelatinous sand texture instead
of a regular sand texture.
Kinda want just let
that one sit,
and then I'll get another cup
for the green powder.
[Music]
Green powder.
Static electricity that makes
it stick to the walls
in some spots.
[Music]
Let's add a little bit more water.
See how that goes.
[Music]
Pretty similar result.
We're getting sort
of a gelatinous sand,
but I wouldn't say
that it's turned
back into slime.
Well it seems to have used up quite
a bit of its water though.
So let's give it some more.
[Music]
We're definitely
getting some results
It does seem to be
absorbing the water,
at least somewhat.
But it took a long time
to dehydrate,
so I wonder if it will take
a long time to rehydrate.
So what we're going to do is
fill both of these cups
with a fair amount of water,
and then just let
them sit overnight,
and see what they turn into.
Will they turn back
into the same kind
of slime they were before?
Or have we changed
something fundamentally
by dehydrating them?
Our slime powders
have now been sitting
in water for several days,
really trying to let
them soak up just as much
as they possibly could.
Let's take a look
at how they've turned out.
Our purple one is
the homemade stuff,
and you can pretty clearly see
that there appears to be just
a layer of water
on top of whatever
is formed down there.
What has formed down there?
Okay.
This is a little bit
like slime.
It's definitely
got more texture,
but it is behaving pretty
similarly to slime.
Stretch it out.
Squish it down.
It's slimy.
It's oozy.
It's not quite the same
as it was before,
but I'd call that
still some slime.
Purple, slightly grainy slime.
All right, let's take a look
at our green slime.
This doesn't have
the same clear water on the top.
I think it is
a little bit thicker
farther down in the cup.
I don't know.
That's looking
pretty slimy to me.
[Music]
Once again,
there's-- I think
there's just a little bit
of a texture to it that
wasn't there before.
[Music]
It's not even.
There's some thicker parts
to our slime,
and there's some runny parts
that you can't really get a hold of.
I feel like when it yeah,
when it comes from the store,
I feel like it's really really smooth,
almost like it's green pudding.
This looks a little bit granular.
It looks like if you took
purple food coloring,
and poured it into a diaper,
and then took all the junk out.
It's about the same consistency.
Dehydrating works very well.
Rehydrating?
It takes a fair amount of time,
and it doesn't give you quite
the same consistency,
but we were able
to make powderized slime,
and turn it back into real slime.
Guys, that's all
I've got for today,
but the fun doesn't end here.
That box up at the top
will take you directly
to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
And if you haven't subscribe
to our channel,
just hit this bomb
to join the club,
and that way, you
will never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.